through all these evidence sessions the
one thing that's concerned me has been
the money
follow the money Colin BT is a veteran
Scottish nationalist a man who's been in
charge of the smp's finances for most of
the past two decades
the party's Treasurer seen here on
Monday after being arrested detained by
detectives investigating finances of
Scotland's biggest political machine now
his resignation from the role he noted
it has not been easy but it is the right
decision to avoid further distraction
from the important work being led by
Hamza Yusuf he said to improve the snp's
governance and transparency
SNP regime is paralyzed by Scandal
something recognized by Hamza yusuf's
Deputy the party has to get his house in
order uh that's what the public would
expect the public would also expect as
though as a government to tackle the
issues of importance to them not least
the cost of living crisis I don't think
anyone is going to dispute that the
governance Arrangements in the party
were not as they should be
um and we are talking about the the
result of some of that now and so those
governance Arrangements absolutely need
to be overhauled a culture created at
SMP headquarters Peter Morrow was until
recently the smp's chief executive in
post since 1999 arrested by police as
part of the same Finance probe before
being released without charge he's
married to Nicholas sturgeon she too
recently suddenly quit as leader of the
party and first Minister her team
insisting she will cooperate with police
if requested Colin Beatty began
overseeing SMP financial matters in
2004. he was replaced briefly in 2020
but his his successor quit claiming he
did not have access to the information
to do the job Colin Beatty then returned
and Hamza Yusuf a close Ally of the
sturgeon era seen as the continuity
candidate when she stood down and now
first Minister tackling a party engulfed
in crisis this Scandal leaves the SNP in
an even deeper hole it is now without a
permanent chief executive and has an
unexpected vacancy for the role of
Treasurer all the while the party
doesn't have Auditors looking after its
Financial accounts after the last firm
resigned and the police investigation is
intensifying the toughest job in
politics at the beginning of a
Premiership already mired in Scandal
Conor Gillis Sky News Edinburgh